anie samson luc ferrandez bonsoir
bonsoir
je vous fais entendre deux extraits on
parle du retour du baseball premiers
sujets il y a eu cette rencontre entre
la mairesse et stephen bronfman en écho
ton avis il n'y aura pas d'argent public
des montréalais des montréalaises dans
dans ce projet là dans la construction
d'un stade ceci étant dit c'est un
projet qu'on trouve intéressant on le
dit depuis le début mais évidemment il
ya des étapes à suivre est la prochaine
étape pour nous c'est que le groupe b ce
bal souhait face une mise à jour à la
population puisse parler leurs projets
de leurs visions et également de
répondre aux questions parce qu'il y en
a beaucoup tout le monde connaît que
c'est très bon j'ai pour les pros le
québec et pour le soc est encore amené
tous ensemble quitte les mêmes ici
[Musique]
avec toutes les partenaires
et c'est sûr que ça va continuer et
c'est pas juste aux établissements ça
c'est un centre militaire pour montréal
ça va axer les douze compagnies savez
quelque chose magnifique hanks à
montréal ça va juste me donner
il dit annie et luc monsieur ben patch
n'est pas qu'un stade de base-ball savez
un centre magnifique un bon être vous
êtes vous convaincu et avait voir de
voir le projet en fait annie mais la
première des choses c'est faut qu'on
voie le projet l'on ne bouge bien body
cellphone ce sens vient le faudrait
savoir c'est quoi qu'est ce que cela
implique et dans la liste des priorités
lorsqu'on prend les décisions bouillot
la viola est ce que c'est important est
ce que c'est nécessaire ou c'est nice
doivent est là actuellement là c'est
plus le fun de la voir quels seront les
impacts pour montréal mais surtout les
retombées et tant qu'on n'aura pas
toutes ces informations là on a beau en
parler le mais c'est parce que cet
accord s'est pas encore concret et le
contre on prend que la mairesse ne peut
pas fermer la porte un projet de
développement important pour mon rien
exactement un pur plus assez ne peut pas
tirer d'un coin ya trois ans lorsqu'elle
avait descendu des escaliers de l'hôtel
de ville bras dessus bras dessous avec
monsieur bré hoffman mais là ce qu'elle
souhaiterait c'est que la population
refuse le projet c'est mon hypothèse
c'est à dire que quand elle dit on va
voir que la population va en penser en
consultation publique elle ne veut pas
avant l'odieux de dire non elle même
mais elle vaut bien s'apercevoir que
pour la population de point de ses
charmes notamment puis pour une grande
proportion des montréalais jusqu'à 80%
des mémoires et des ne veulent pas que
de l'argent public dans un stade de
baseball au centre-ville il va y avoir
de réaction forte et là pourrait
peut-être s'appuyer sur cette réaction
forte là pour dire non mais est-ce que
annick je vous pose là est-ce que le
projet ne pourrait pas être
extraordinaire pour tout le monde est-ce
qu'on pourrait peut plus clair le
problème vous allez me dire on ne le
sait pas encore il est un peu trop tôt
pour le dire mais c'est une question
petit pour une position extrêmement
intéressante montréal c'est pas un
village mariage c'est la plus grande
c'est la métropole c'est là métropole du
québec donc il ne mettra pas l'un des
grands projets mais il faut que ces
projets soient viables et c'est plus sur
cette partie là qu'on doit vraiment
poussé voir qu'est ce que les
montréalais vont gagner de ce oui
peut-être des investissements la ville
mettra pas d'argent mais auto on pourra
négocier la ville pourrait négocier des
logements communautaires pourrait
négocier plein de choses c'est là qu'on
est rendu qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir de
ça qu'est ce que les montréalais vont
gagner de cela parce que c'est un gros
projet si l'argent vient pas de montréal
et des montréalais mais on peut
bénéficier des retombées économiques
parce qu'il va avoir des tas tu vas
avoir des emplois mais pour ça il faut
aller
voir un lieu animé tout à fait si encore
une fois car j'ai ouimette mais ça
dépend ce qu'on met dedans quand il dit
qu'il va animer 12 mois par année est ce
que par exemple il pourrait y avoir un
calendrier de spectacles rock 40 jours
par année ou des choses comme celles là
très intéressant pour la scène
culturelle peut-être d'abord point
intéressant pour les concurrents un
monsieur bronfman mais bon mettons ce
soit intéressant est ce que c'est
intéressant pour le quartier qui est
autour est-ce que ça va être quand on
dit on retrouve m billets des choses qui
sont qu'ils ne peuvent pas être mises
ensemble si par exemple il y avait 40 60
70 spectacles de rock à cet endroit là
par annie ça ne peut pas aller dans un
quartier résidentiel donc faut attendre
de voir ce qui va y avoir deux devant on
va t'en on va attendre on n'a pas le
choix d'attendre parce que pas de
maquette n'y a pas de projet la demi
équipe ses potes l'air avec tampa bay je
veux vous parler montréal est une ville
universitaire les universités c'est
important dans l'adn de montréal
l'histoire de vin rouge et vin rusca
lieutenant duval avait on le sait je
ratais la controverse en 2d elle avait
prononcé le mot en haine dans sa classe
à verser d'ottawa grosse controverse a
été suspendue y avait pas de processus
et s'est sentie
tassé sans aucun autre autre forme de
procès il ya deux des cas dans les
universités ou des gens dit il faut
faire attention les professeurs doivent
faire attention où aux agressions ils
doivent avertir or aujourd'hui alexandre
cloutier qui accouche d'un rapport avec
d'autres gens
on va écouter deux extraits de monsieur
cloutier et on va faire c'est monnaie
courante que les universités sont régies
par le gouvernement du québec nous on
pense que sur un enjeu aussi fondamental
que la mission l'université ces
conditions d'exercice l'autonomie
universitaire la liberté universitaire
honnêtement monsieur roy à notre avis le
gouvernement ne fait rien la censure
reste malheureusement de s'amplifier au
québec parce que la situation elle est
déjà à nos yeux à nous comme un temps
relativement problématique
celle inverse d'un simple space une
salle de classe a fait une salle de
classe c n'est pas exempt d'émotion ce
n'est pas exempt de réaction ça ne veut
pas dire pour autant qu'il y ait pas d
élèves qui peuvent se sentir heurter
qu'il ya des gens en raison de leurs
véhicules qui peuvent pas vivre des
moments difficiles ce qu'on dit aussi
c'est que les universités doivent
adopter une politique sur la liberté
universitaire et bien identifier les
ressources d'accompagnement pour des
besoins ponctuels que peuvent vivre
certains élèves en raison de leur
situation qui est bien particulière
alors vous l'avez entendu et 10 en deux
mots il dit qu'il a été étonné de voir
le nombre d'enseignants de professeurs
devraient agir qui lui ont dit qu'il se
sentait prêt dans une espèce de censure
qui marchait sur des oeufs il dit ça
prend une loi pour pour encadrer sol
pour donner un espace liberté dans les
salles de cours ça veut pas dire
insulter les gens pour insulter les gens
ça veut dire de pouvoir discuter en
réaction l'udc avant je trouve que son
rapport est extrêmement sévère et
l'université aura aucune marge de
manoeuvre après avoir appliqué les
différentes recommandations
il est très très clairs l'université
d'abord la classe politique space alors
il l'étudiant doit s'attendre à ce qu'il
y ait des discussions qui ne lui font
pas plaisir ensuite les traumatise
trauma avertissements donc le
possibilité que le professeur nomme un
mot ou une problématique qui surprennent
l'élève c'est à la discrétion du
professeur ensuite universités est
obligé de défendre le professeur ou la
personne qui fait preuve de liberté
d'expression si elle est prise dans un
débat maintenant avec les étudiants
finalement l'inversé objets d'encadrer
les médias sociaux dans la mesure du
possible lors de ces lots des crises qui
sont liées au déroulement je ne dis pas
que je non non je sais pas qui va trop
loin je dis qu'il est allé aussi loin
qu'il pouvait aller pour encadrer
l'université annie je trouve que son
rapport touche pas mal à toute la
problématique par c'est pas juste avec
le lieutenant duval messous l université
mcgill à l'uqam à concordia ou lieu à
différentes problématiques
je pense que la liberté et l'autonomie
universitaire elle est importante et
cette loi-là qui seront régies pour
l'ensemble des universités vont - ils
l'encadré et après ça chaque université
et met en place un comité qui pourront
voir s'il ya des litiges ce comité local
pour aller décider mais je crois que
c'est important on en est rendu là
écoutez dans le rapport à 60% le vu
tantôt dans les chiffres 60 % des
professeurs se sont auto censuré pour ne
pas pour ne pas déranger les jeunes
insiste un lieu où on peut discuter à
l'université c'est bien là c'est là
qu'on se fait des idées c'est là qu'on
peu près des débats ces locaux on
apprend à échanger mais si on peut plus
le faire ça sert à quoi et aussi dans
cette loi là je pense pas que beaucoup
de monde beaucoup de jeunes qui vont
être content parce que 80% de ceux qui
ont répondu au sondage parce que quand
même il ya fait des sondages futiles 80
pour ça que c'est ces jeunes le se sont
dits qui pour eux il n'y a aucun
problème qui ne voit aucun problème à ce
qui se passe en même temps le recteur
merci de montréal qui a dit écoutons nos
projets de l'état pourrait gérer ça chez
nous mieux comme simon là dessus
effectivement c'est pas toutes les
universités ont besoin d'être mieux
quelques anniversaires qui ont fait
preuve d'un manque de jugement qui fait
que toutes les mrc maintenant on est
pris dans un carcan qui est un peu
dommage parce que ça aurait dû gérer au
niveau des universités on verra ça c'est
une recommandation qu'il loi on verra si
loin il y aura et quand et comment et
tout ça merci beaucoup à vous deux bonne
soirée à vous n'en croirez au revoir